gold it's captivated everyone from kings
to bond villains but unless it's jewelry
most of us just don't get our hands on
the stuff
[Music]
one man keen to capitalize on that is
the ceo of talimani cameron perry who is
now offering his workers the chance to
switch from pounds to pence to gold
first of all i just wanted to ask you
why gold
uh well really the journey for tally was
we needed to design a better form of
money than what the
the mainstream money is which is fiat
currency which is debt based
and
because that has some uh systemic
problems with it uh and one that people
feel a lot is the devaluation that goes
on constantly through inflation
so that devaluation by design that made
really it was trying to design a better
form of money and if you're going to
design something that's accountable to
something it needs to have an anchor and
you know gold historically has been
chosen for good reason as a fantastic
anchor to a money supply and so that's
why we use gold it's really easy to
understand
everybody in the world understands that
it's valuable this type of thing
the uk job market is red hot right now
with graduate salaries up seven percent
this year alone so will cameron's offer
glitter for prospective employees or
will it just attract gold diggers what
do people think about this almost in a
sense is it a gimmick are they keen to
be paid in it well we wouldn't force
anyone to be paid in it because it does
take a little bit of
a while for the common sense of it just
to resonate through and for people to
feel comfortable
and you know and i should reiterate
you're quite right it it can fluctuate
you know a little bit so if you're
really living hand to mouth it's
probably not the answer but if you're
just dealing in tally you're dealing in
a very easy to understand thing
every unit of currency has the value of
one milligram of gold crypto currencies
have seen huge growth in recent years
but lately they appear to be losing some
of their luster so will tally go for
gold or come out in last place apart
from being hard to understand how it
derives its value and that it's volatile
it's also very clunky to use so one
important thing with tally is that you
get
you get an everyday account you get a
debit card you use it just as you use
money at the moment and that's quite
important if you're going to introduce a
new product to put it in a familiar
environment tally's obviously your
platform it's been your brainchild
is this just a massive pr stunt cameron
well i suppose if we're designing a
better well we have designed a better
form of money and it protects and
benefits the account holder rather than
the financial institution
um and it got some pr around the fact
people are getting paid in gold but as
we've discussed they're not getting
handed chunks of bullion or anything
they're getting paid in in a currency
that represents the value of gold that
we vote on their behalf this is this is
one of the things that we need
competition in money if you consider
that money is just a product
as a as a society we shouldn't be stuck
in a monopoly of this one product that
hasn't been had any innovation for the
last 50 years i don't know of any other
industry where they've got a leading
product and there's no innovation on it
for five decades um that that's some of
the problems with monopolies right
so competition um you know leads to
better outcomes for consumers tally's
all about choice a lot of people
will choose to stay in pounds which is
fantastic but because of tally they can
choose that rather than be forced to
because there's no choice so for many
this will not be the right choice but
for some it will have a real glittering
appeal bloomberg's golden girl leanne
garens